tomorrow's Manigault Newman is with us
in studio 57 her new memoir unhinged is
published by a division of Simon &
Schuster which is owned by CBS good
morning good morning let's start with
the tape you said you had done some
taping when you were fired to protect
yourself but this is during the campaign
things in the middle of a campaign the
moment we start talking about the N word
tape I was surprised as you heard on
that recording how no one doubt it that
he said it and in fact they had worked
to try to suppress this tape for so long
and everyone says he said it he's
embarrassed he doesn't want this to come
out and now they're saying they have
never heard these allegations and it's
ironic that these are high-level
campaign staffers we're talking about
how to react why you were taping why
were you sleeping because the truth
matters Gail and in fact if I didn't
have this tape you always probably
wondering if in fact they did talk about
it she mentions Kellyanne on the tape
and says that she talked to Kelly Ann or
Kelly and discussed this with the
president United States and now he's
tweeting at me saying that he never said
it is not in his vocabulary when he
discussed this on Trump Force One during
the campaign but stepping back from the
specifics I take the question with
everything you're saying and you're
coming forward you were taping during
the campaign oh yeah there is this
question about your credibility and the
fact that you were kind of already
taping things and working behind the
scenes during the campaign my father had
an expression you know we can't hear you
because your actions are speaking more
loudly why are people supposed to pay
attention to what you're saying now when
you're the kind of person who would be
taping campaign press conferences or
phone calls in the middle of the
campaign yes I'm the kind of person who
covers her own back and Trump world
everyone lies everyone says one thing
one day and they changed their story the
next day I wanted to have this type of
documentation so that in the event I
found myself in this position where as
you said they're questioning my
credibility saying they never discussed
the n-word tape they had never heard
these accusations the president had
never heard these accusations when in
fact this tape proves that they
discussed it at high levels of the Trump
campaign well Frank Luntz reached out to
me because you said he had heard him he
said you never called him emailed him no
I did it in fact Katrina he said I've
never heard the president use that well
it's important in on
I never say that I spoke to him Katrina
Pierson the spokesperson for the Trump
campaign says on that recording that she
communicated with him and that he had
heard it I speak very clearly in this
chapter about what happened between
Katrina and Franklin he's absolutely
right I never spoke to him never reached
out to him I was simply he says
reporting what was on this he says why
do you want to work in a world as you
say where everybody lies why do you want
to be I've been in politics for 20 years
everybody lies in politics I worked in
the Clinton administration during the
Monica Lewinsky scandal where he first
said he never had relations with her and
we found out that that was a lie I
learned very early on in politics that
this is a cutthroat world and you have
to be tough 20 years in the way in
politics and I've learned some lessons
number one you have to look out for
yourself and two things change
relationships change and people always
protect themselves you have to look out
there conflicting reports as to when you
first heard the tape where the president
allegedly uses the n-word there are
reports that you heard this last year
while you were still working in the
administration last year I do first here
I did not hear it until after I closed
the book and had an opportunity to fly
out to California and the person allowed
me to hear it had I heard it while I was
working in the White House I would have
left immediately so so let's say that
tape exists now what what is the purpose
of so the tape comes out we hear it what
do you hope will come out of this well
the sad thing is as we saw with Access
Hollywood
it probably won't impact his base I
think that their support has baked in
but it does expose him for the races
that he is you also said that you and
the president in your book have a
symbiotic relationship that you two used
each other what is the nature of your
relationship
Omarosa there's all sorts of rumors
about you and Donald Trump can you tell
us what is the nature of what was the
nature of your relationship I know
you're happily married I just met your
husband backstage very nice I very
handsome smart talented you said he's
John Allen Newman but what is the nature
of your relationship with my mentor yeah
he was my mentor for many many years
and you know in 2003 I wanted to be like
him I grew up in extreme poverty in
Youngstown Ohio
and I aspire to be a billionaire one day
and what better way to become a
billionaire than to study under a
billion the two of you never had a
romantic relationship solutely not well
you've heard that rumor I'm sure that's
a that's a charge that's launched
against successful women to kind of
degrade them and undermine their success
I'm very well educated I have incredible
experience and I have never had to
leverage sex to get any where I needed
to go so what do you hope will come out
of all of this I think the truth matters
and I believe that we should keep the
truth as a priority in this
administration they struggle with the
truth and they construct their own
reality deceiving the American people
very quickly you have everything that
you say in the book backed up by tape or
email absolutely if you see it in quotes
it can't be verified who operate it and
it's well document and you keep it's
almost feels like a form of blackmail
with the tapes either release the tape
I'm not asking for anything I'm telling
my story unhinged I'm telling my story
and unhinged if you get the book you see
the quotes it is back up and verified
Amoroso we appreciate you joining us
thank you for having me